so I was looking at the Christmas tree
the other day and our thinking the
lights on it are really nice and pretty
but they're quite plain and while you
can get some that flash or others that
come in different colors I thought could
we using a computer do something a bit
more interesting could we make some of
the computer controlled so I was
inspired to build a set of Christmas
tree lights that are actually controlled
by the Raspberry Pi computer the nice
thing about the Raspberry Pi is that
like the BBC micro before it it's very
easy to integrate it with electronics
project and very simple electronic
projects like this because it has a set
of input/output ports that you can use
to program things now on their own these
generated enough of voltage you can just
connect them directly to an LED and it
will light up so the input/output ports
are great because you can set the
Raspberry Pi up very easily and software
to have some of the ports as inputs
others as outputs in this case I've
configured them all as outputs and what
this means is I can set bits in the
computer's memory or what appears to be
the computer's memory and it will turn
the output on or it'll turn the output
off under my software control now an LED
has two legs on it so the short one is
known as the cathode and the long one is
known as the anode and the voltage has
to flow from the anode through the
cathode back down to ground now we can
connect a very resistor the anode
directly to one of the output ports on
the Raspberry Pi and then just connect
the short leg of the cathode to the
ground and we can then program the ledge
to come on and off as we choose so I
started off my project by just
prototyping that up by putting several
LEDs onto my red board here and just
linking them up to the Raspberry Pi and
it worked really nicely the programming
is really simple I just grabbed off the
web a simple example and modified it to
do what I wanted to do but I did more
Christmas tree lights and there were
output pins on the Raspberry Pi so what
I did was I used these which are eight
flip-flops in a single chip these allow
you to remember what the raspberry PI's
output is even if it changes so these
have got eight memory locations and
we'll look at them in more due
in a forthcoming video how they work but
what I can do is I can pull up eight
outputs and set this chip to remember
them and thence the apples from this
chip will always remember what that
worse if the lead was going to be on or
off it'll remember that and I can then
move on to program the next one for as
many as I wanted so effectively I can
multiplex as it were the outputs of the
Raspberry Pi to as many LEDs as I wanted
so I take seven of the outputs from the
Raspberry Pi and I feed them to the
flip-flops or inside these chips and I
connect them both to the two chips I'm
using and it just it want a bit 1 bit 2
bit to the same which is where I got all
these wires here which are linking the
two chips together I also have two wires
that come from the Raspberry Pi that go
one to the first year and one to the
second chip and these are enabled me to
program either the first chip or the
second chip so what I do I set the data
for the first seven LEDs and then say to
that chip I want you to remember this
and it goes to the LEDs and their output
that pattern and then I press up those
outputs on the Raspberry Pi for the
second set of LEDs and so remember that
to the other chip and it remembers them
and they come up with this pattern so I
built the circuit up on the breadboard
and as you can see I'm still got some of
the LEDs on here with the 14 LEDs on the
actual loom breadboard and tested it
like that so I run it on there for a
while and then I had to start the
process of soldering together all the
LEDs onto the wires so I could dangle
these around to the Christmas tree and
Babbage helped me with the soldering
Babbage is a sort of mascot for the
Raspberry Pi that you can get as a toy
so also built the hardware I was able to
start developing the software that was
going to control this at the moment the
software still very very basic and he's
actually based off an example I found
online so it's basically just a very
simple C program that allows me to turn
by writing into the memory space of the
computer the pins on off in a bit
pattern so what I'm working on at the
moment is to be able to specify what
sort of pattern you want to go up and
down the LEDs are giving it a simple
things that says this LED is on then
this one's off then move them along one
or reverse them so they go into
different backgrounds who knows I might
even get it so you can tweet the
Christmas tree with the pattern you
wanted to display
we were all using this at full rate all
the time
so we're all going yeah then it just
wouldn't what it would do was to return
the signal back fire a different stud on
the left-hand rotor so it would take a
different journey back through the
machine to the way it came in